[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france 24 que notre invité
aujourd'hui et joseph poussé le ministre
des affaires étrangères de taïwan il est
avec nous depuis qu'a été merci d'être
avec nous monsieur le ministre
merci à vous votre présidence à higuain
dans son message de nouvel an a prévenu
la chine de renoncer à tout aventurisme
militaire
à quel point la menace militaire
chinoise et sérieuse contre pas
alors je dois dire qu'elle est très
sérieuse
regardez les préparations militaires du
côté chinois la chine à moderniser son
équipement militaire a renforcé ses
entraînements ces services étaient si
vous vous penchez sur le niveau des
exercices militaires autour de taiwan
que ce soit dans les airs ou la surface
où leurs capacités balistiques on voit
que il ya une forte amélioration ces
dernières années la chine a fait
énormément d'investissements dans ses
capacités militaires et la chine a
également commencé à parler d'envahir
taïwan
voilà la situation
regardez l'année dernière
il ya eu plus de 900 sortie par
l'aviation militaire pratiquement 1000
sortie évidemment c'est très intimidant
pour les taiwanais et c'est très
menaçant oui mais est-ce que vous pensez
vraiment que la chine se prépare à une
invasion une frappe militaire ou est ce
que c'est juste de discours de
l'intimidation
c'est une très bonne question
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui disent
que la chine pourrait attaquer taïwan
deux ans dans six ans dans dix ans
peu importe le nombre d'années la chine
risque d'attaqué taiwan ce que nous
voyons c'est que la chine commence à se
préparer
nous constatons également que la chine
parle des actions militaires contre
taïwan et ce à tous les niveaux
du niveau le plus élevé au grade et
militaires par les dirigeants civils
également et donc la situation n'est pas
bonne pour nous
face à cette situation nous n'avons pas
le choix nous devons nous préparer
qu'ils attaquent taiwan l'année
prochaine ou dans deux ans ou dans dix
ans nous devons nous préparer nous
devons être prêts et donc nous essayons
de nous préparer contre où nous préparer
à une action militaire de la chine que
ce soit une invasion totale ou des
petites échauffourées avec notre aprr
mais nous sommes déterminés à nous
défendre et nous investissons également
dans notre défense nous nous préparons à
une guerre asymétrique nous essayons de
nous préparer à nous préparer à une
guerre hybride voilà ce que nous
essayons de faire nous essayons d'être
prêt à une potentielle attaque militaire
chinois oui mais il ya clairement un
déséquilibre militaire entre vous et les
militaires chinois et c'est là que les
états unis rentrer dans l'équation les
etats-unis se sont engagés à plusieurs
reprises à défendre taiwan secrétaire
d'état anthony blinken a dit il ya un
mois que tout mouvement de la chine pour
envahir taiwan aurait des conséquences
terribles selon ses propres mots mais
vous devez savoir que les états unis ne
vont sans doute pas aller en guerre
contre la chine si jamais ils attaquent
taiwan est ce que vous pensez vraiment
que les états unis irait en guerre
contre la chine pour vous défendre
il ne m'appartient pas de répondre à
cette question mais c'est absolument
crucial pour vous de le savoir oui je
sais mais c'est aux états unis de
considérer si taiwan est suffisamment
important pour qu'ils décident
d'intervenir
quoi qu'il en soit nous devons nous
préparer
nous devons
nous sommes responsables de défendre
taiwan nous sommes responsables de nous
défendre ce que nous demandons de la
part des états unis c'est qu'ils
continuent à respecter leurs engagements
en vertu du taiwan
en vertu de cette loi les etats-unis
sont engagés à apporter suffisamment de
matériel de défense à taiwan également à
nous aider à nous aider à former nos
forces
après par et et je peux vous dire en
toute transparence que les états unis
travaillent avec acharnement dans ce but
nous avons a fait l'acquisition d'armes
avancés de la part des états unis et
nous conduisons également des
discussions militaires avec les états
unis pour que taiwan soit en mesure de
se défendre ces dernières années ce que
j'ai vu c'est à une augmentation du
niveau de coopération entre taiwan et
les états unis que ce soit dans le
domaine des échanges de renseignements
ou pour à offrir des armes avancées à
taïwan vous former nos équipes où nous
aider à moderniser notre force de
réserve voilà tout ce dont nous avons
besoin et je peux vous dire en toute
transparence une fois de plus que nous
comprenons bien que défendre taiwan et
notre responsabilité et nous sommes
absolument déterminés à nous défendre
mais en cas d' attaquer ce que vous
attendez que les des troupes américaines
stationnées au japon par exemple
interviennent est ce que c'est ça qui
est discuté en ce moment
ce dont nous avons discuté avec les
états unis comme je le dit précédemment
c'est que les etats unis doivent
apporter à taïwan suffisamment de
matériel militaire et également nous
aider à former nos soldats afin que
taiwan soit en mesure de se défendre
nous avons bien conscience qu'aucun
autre pays n'est responsable de défendre
taïwan il nous appartient de nous
défendre le président chinois de chez
jean ping s'est engagé à gouverner
taïwan selon le système un pays deux
systèmes
est-ce que vous lui faites confiance à
ce que ce sera le cas évidemment quand
on voit s'il vient de se passer à hong
kong
on ne peut pas faire confiance aux
chinois lorsqu'ils disent qu'ils
promettent quelque chose à taïwan
le gouvernement chinois avancent que si
taiwan rejoint la chine dans le cadre
d'un modèle un pays deux systèmes nous
aurons réellement voix au chapitre dans
le cadre de l fication mais regardez ce
qui s'est passé regarder ce qu'ils ont
fait à certaines de nos propriétés
lorsque certains pays ont coupé leur
lien avec taïwan ils ont aider ce pays à
prendre le contrôle de nos propriétés le
nicaragua
oui le nicaragua et regarder la
situation à hong kong une chose est très
claire le modèle un pays deux systèmes
pour la chine c'est juste un pays et pas
de système le gouvernement chinois a
promis à hong kong qu'il n'allait pas
changer son système politique
à un horizon de 50 ans à partir de 1997
mais regardez ce qui s'est passé l'année
dernière et cette année la liberté a
disparu hong kong était fier très fier
de son ouverture de ces libertés mais
aujourd'hui tout cela a disparu toute
l'opposition
tous les défenseurs de la démocratie ont
été emprisonnés ou disqualifier du
système politique et donc à hong kong
aujourd'hui on voit qu'il n'ya qu'un
seul système le système autoritaire
chinois est bien évidemment taiwan ne
souhaite pas suivre cet exemple taïwan
est une démocratie fier à les taiwanais
m la situation actuelle nous allons nous
défendre et nous allons défendre notre
mode de vie démocratique mais monsieur
le ministre vous avez dû remarquer que
tout ce qui s'est passé à hong kong et
qui continue d'ailleurs de nos jours
l'occident condamné certes mais n'a rien
fait
sacré quand même un précédent peut-être
pour taiwan peut-être que l'occident
voit condamner mais à la fin et regardez
ce qui se passe à hong kong les chinois
font exactement ce qu'ils ont dit qu'ils
voulaient faire sans beaucoup de
protestations
la situation à hong kong est très
différente de celle de taiwan
si on pense à hong kong à l'heure de la
rétrocession hong kong a été rétrocédée
à la chine avec sa souveraineté schiff
donc le chef militaire et est
sélectionnée a été choisi par les
chinois et c'est l'armée chinoise qui
était déjà à hong kong et donc hong kong
n'a pas le même niveau de souveraineté
que taiwan
regardez taiwan aujourd'hui nous avons
notre propre présidente
élu démocratiquement
nous avons notre propre parlement nous
avons notre propre ministre des affaires
étrangères et notre propre ministre de
la défense nationale
et notre armée est capable de défendre
le territoire donc notre situation est
très différente lorsque le gouvernement
chinois a décidé d'imposer une loi sur
la sécurité nationale à hong kong et
bien les hong kong n ont pas pu dire non
mais à taiwan les chinois n'ont pas de
juridiction sur taïwan et donc les
chinois ne pourront pas faire ce qu'ils
ont fait à hong kong
par ailleurs il ya une prise de
conscience de la part de la communauté
internationale
regardez les discussions à haut niveau
entre les dirigeants mondiaux en format
de plus deux avec le ministre des
affaires étrangères et les menaces de la
défense
il y à plus de 20 reprises l'année
dernière
l'importance de la paix de la stabilité
sur le détroit de taiwan a été évoquée
encore encore et encore et je pense donc
il ya une prise de conscience de la part
de la communauté internationale à savoir
que le statu quo au à taïwan doit être
préservé il y a quelques semaines taïwan
a ouvert sa première ambassade de facto
dans l'union européenne en lituanie en
appelant le bureau taiwan plutôt que
le nom habituel taipei en réaction la
chine a rétrogradé ses relations
diplomatiques avec la lituanie vous avez
fourni de l'aide économique à la
lituanie ma question est simple est-ce
que vous espérez que d'autres pays
européens vont suivre le même chemin et
même peut-être les états unis votre
rallye le plus proche et changer le nom
nous n'allons pas nous fermé à cette
idée mais pour le moment nous n'en
faisons pas une priorité
pour le moment nous allons essayer de
protéger nos relations avec la lituanie
il y a beaucoup de personnes qui ont
parlé de ce nom représentations
taïwanaise en lituanie est aussi de
savoir si c'était réellement une
provocation envers la chine
et c'est cela risquait d'entraîner des
mesures de rétorsion de la part de la
chine
contre la lituanie mais si on se penche
sur la situation dans le monde vous nous
appelez taiwan les états unis ont une
institution l'institution américaines à
taïwan
l'union européenne appelle taiwan taiwan
les pays européens appellent taiwan
taiwan
et donc
que l'on s'appelle taiwan chez nous ou à
l'étranger
c'est tout simplement une description de
la réalité
et ce sont les chinois qui sont
insultants offensant alors qu'ils
essaient de changer le nom taiwan
en autre chose
notre participation lorsque l'on
participe dans les grandes organisations
internationales
et bien la chine nous décrit comme une
province de la chine province taïwanaise
de la chine c'est insultant pour les
taiwanais parce que nous ne sommes pas
nous ne relevons pas de la juridiction
chinoise et donc nous espérons que les
états unis ou les grands pays européens
comprennent kappeler taiwan taiwan
taiwan que les taiwanais s'appelle des
taiwan et ce n'est pas une provocation
la provocation c'est lorsque les chinois
changent notre nom à autre chose
je vais vous merci beaucoup d'avoir été
l'invitée de france 24 depuis taipei
merci à vous d'avoir suivi cet entretien
sur nos antennes l'information continue
sur freenews
[Musique]